foreign
to Chattanooga and talk to Amanda what's
up Amanda
Hi how are you hi I'm doing great how
about you
I am okay
okay I will I will revise my answer and
say I'm okay too what's up
um so I'm calling because uh my husband
had a dysfunctional whatever you want to
say relationship with alcohol
um
and it just kept spiraling out of
control and led to the point where it
caused
a giant issue with me and our kids and
it started affecting our kids so giant
issue like abuse or screaming and
yelling okay like screaming yelling
verbal
um
questions of physical but nothing I ever
saw
um but I mean what do you mean questions
like a kid saying he hit them
um
in the head so
um and that was an issue and that led to
me removing
myself and the children from the
situation
um for a period of time until there were
signs of improvement
um and that Improvement came
um of stopping drinking and there was
anger and then remorse came and then
once we kind of reunified as a family
the remorse went away and the anger just
stayed
um and so I don't know how to move
forward in this we're in marriage
counseling
um
and a lot of it's just
there wants to be blame place on
everyone but himself and he'll own that
the drinking was a problem but he won't
own
the anger and the I mean the things that
come along with things like that where
you just your marriage is going to start
falling apart when something like that
is in the house so can I be can I be
real honest with you
unfortunately
throughout my career I've had the honor
and
like heartbreaking responsibility of
sitting with women in a very abusive
relationships
and there's a very
um similar
evasive way they communicate
and I'm hearing that language with you
because if you were to actually lay out
in systematic order here's what happens
here's what me and my kids experience
you would be faced with I know what I
have to do
yeah
is that fair
probably yes I want to honor your
evasive language I'm not going to press
you on it yeah
but I'm gonna throw a couple things out
that you can either say yay or no or you
can just not even answer okay yeah
you can
come home or let me put this way when
that car or truck drives up
your heart starts beating faster
and either your kids start getting a
little bit maniacal or they go hide
and you don't feel safe in your own
house or you're always looking to see
where every kid is and what's their
relationship with Dad
some of that's true some isn't
um
he's a like he's a great father
um and he loves the kids everyone can
hit one of your kids in the head
yes okay
um
I want you to revise what you just said
he's good fathers who love their kids
don't get hammered and hit their kids in
the head
yeah
and I'm a father and so I'm just going
to stand by that statement yeah no
that's true
um
and if they do
they are on their face in the mud and
gravel yeah saying they're sorry and
they will go to hell and back to get
well and heal themselves so that crap
never happens again
yeah and
there's just a blame there's no
ownership there's some ownership and
then it's like well this happened and
you did this and you do this to me and
our life is like this because you do
this and it's just okay let me ask you I
mean I'm asking is some of that what are
you saying true or no is it all nonsense
um some is true yeah like the the like
um like we have communication problems
in our marriage and I asked him to stop
drinking several times and he wouldn't
and when he went and stopped drinking I
just distanced myself from him um
because every time I would hang out with
him it would
uh turn into either a fight or he would
make a snarky comment at me and it was
just what is what specifically is he
saying that you do
that I control our lives and I give him
no control
and then I asked him and he says that I
need to make changes and I ask him what
changes and then I am not given any
response
um
y'all are in marriage counseling right
now
so here's what I think the the next step
is because everything feels very
amorphous
and what he needs is a cold dose a cold
splash of water of reality
and that means you have to do the work
of being very specific crystal clear
this stuff changes
or me and kids leave
period
and it was you did that once and you
said the drinking has to stop and it did
what you didn't you what you thought was
with the drinking stops then all this
other crap will stop too
and what you found out the hard way is
drinking was just covering up all this
other stuff and deeper issues
right and so now we have to deal with
the safety issues and we have to deal
with the blame issues we have to deal
with the whatever issues
but if you're going to one of those
therapists that's just like and how do
you feel and how does that make you feel
and how does that make you feel you're
just talking in circles man
yeah and that's not the case but I
I agree
uh like and if the focus is on him right
now because of what's happened
um and he's just like I'm tired of just
talking about me
um
what he thinks you can't control any of
that all you can control is you and I
would be very very specific
and then also if you and your therapist
and him have worked out you're right
Amanda you do do these things
then the onus is on you if you're safe
now now for instance
you don't ever want to have sex with me
that's bullcrap well if you come home
drunk all the time or if you're angry
all the time or if the kids are yelling
and you're on the couch with a beer or
you're on the couch with your feet
propped up going hey are we going to
hook up tonight then no we're not having
sex right so it's within a context but
if there is he walks in the door and you
heard the little your kids away like
little ducklings and then he says well
you disappear every time that's probably
true
and so I'll address those my behavior my
participation in this where I can where
I can keep us safe I will
but I'm going to be very specific about
what I need in my home
and if he says I'm not doing that then
he has made a choice to not participate
in that home because you made a choice
that for his participation to continue
this is the way this has to be
yeah and y'all it sounds like there's
some very
um
it just sounds like somebody at some
point needs to cut through all the well
yeah but you make yeah and everybody's
just got to get through the clarity
because you're doing it to him too right
like I don't know I just like you're
angry well what does that mean well it
just feels let's just be real clear with
each other how's that sound
okay yeah I I but it won't I've tried
because that's but I guess I need to try
again well it's more you have to try and
with your counselor you have to work out
your or what moment
yeah
and that's the other side of this
and sometimes it's a smart thing when
somebody's really struggling with anger
to have
um a very clear designated 30-day
separation
I we need to separate here so that you
can get a grasp of your anger
yeah and there's some rules about that
type of Separation very clear paths and
that type of Separation
um and it's it's it can be very very
healthy
and revealing but because it allows
everybody to be calm because nobody's
having good conversations if he feels
attacked and you feel attacked and that
makes him angry and that makes you shut
down whatever no no one's no one's
getting anything from that but if
there's a agreed upon contract between
the two of you with your therapist we're
gonna take 30 days and and separate here
he moves out you all move out what I
don't care but we're gonna figure it out
that's a common thing with somebody
struggling with anger that just can't
get the rates under control or somebody
who's experienced anger and just their
nervous system won't let them be safe in
their own house first for a second
and maybe that's the path
you just have to sit with your counselor
and come up with your or what statement
you do these things or
yeah
it's made him or no
exactly what that is yeah okay yeah
yeah he keeps saying what are you gonna
do if I drink again
um and that's a great question
yeah what are you gonna do
I don't know you do like every time my
every time that I think about it my mind
just shuts off like because I it it
involves leaving I think
um that's what I say I think you know
yeah
I think you absolutely no
and I also think that he knows you shut
down
the same as you know how to spin him up
yeah that's true
and you never ever do that do you
of course
he needs to have his or what moments
with you
I can't live in a home where somebody's
controlling and and demands this and
this and this and this and this from me
okay he gets to do that and you need to
have your
here's what I need for me and my kids to
feel safe
and if he got drunk and hit your kids in
the head once I promise you it's
happened before and as your mom I mean
as the mom you got to believe your kids
until proven otherwise okay
cool
yes can I just tell you this I hate this
for for you I hate this for your husband
hate this for your kids hate this for
everybody
thank you I hate it for you me too
the words moving forward are Clarity
Clarity Clarity and then a little more
clarity
what do you need what do you want and in
partnership with your counselor with the
marriage counselor
here's my line of demarcation here's
here is my or what statement
and I do think it's fair for him to get
his or what statement to but it's time
for both of y'all to start being very
clear
I hate it for y'all I hate it hate it
hate it
My Hope and prayer for you guys is y'all
are able to
find peace in your home
your husband's able to find peace and
put the needs of his family and your
kids and this thing y'all are have built
that thing y'all built is wobbly and
it's fallen over
but he commits you commit to build
something telling you I hope that's my
hope that's my hope it's gonna be hard
That's My Hope